South Korea's spy agency says North
Korea could carry out more ballistic
missile tests by the end of the year to
boost its ability to threaten the United
States Democrats in Washington are
asking questions about president Trump's
authority to launch nuclear weapons they
worried he might do it on a whim major
Garrett is at the White House
major good morning good morning White
House through its top advisors consider
this anxiety about President Trump's
temperament and nuclear weapons
misplaced it's North Korea they argue
that's volatile reckless and provocative
still what is legal when it comes to
this president and nuclear weapons is a
very real topic do not try US president
Trump's warnings to North Korea have
been vivid and descriptive we will have
no choice but to totally destroy North
Korea the meaning of destroy in the
nuclear age raises this question are the
President's powers unchecked if you
execute an unlawful order you will go to
jail
Air Force General John heightened head
of US Strategic Command tried to answer
the question over the weekend saying
there are limits I provide advice to the
president he'll tell me what to do and
if it's and if it's illegal guess what's
gonna happen you say no I'm gonna say
mr. president still illegal and guess
what he's gonna do he's gonna say what
would be legal and we'll come up with
options Arkansas Republican Tom cotton
said the short time available to respond
to a nuclear attack or one that may be
eminent gives the commander-in-chief
special power the president has to hold
in his hands the sole decision to use
our nuclear weapons since the Cold War
u.s. presidents have had sole authority
to launch nuclear weapons the codes to
do so follow the president in a suitcase
the nuclear football no one human being
should ever have that power
now some Senate Democrats want to say in
pre-emptive nuclear war drafting a bill
requiring Congress declare war first the
President of the United States is so
unstable is so volatile has a
decision-making process that is so
quixotic that he might order a nuclear
weapons strike that hearing war senator
Murphy spoke was the first Congress
convened
since 1976 that was held after it was
learned in the waiting days of the Nixon
presidency President Nixon before he
resigned was often drunk and depressed
raising alarms about nuclear launch
powers and instability inside the Oval
Office mr. Trump's advisers say things
are far more stable now Gale and that
economic and diplomatic pressure are
still the first priority when it comes
to North Korea all right that's good to
know thank you very much major